talk us through this you posted a makeup  tutorial how how many people are  involved in this I think it's it's your  it's your chin like we can say that all  right here it is here's Tandy Newton  doing a makeup tutorial you will want to  try this yourself at home  hey this is Tandy obviously although I  did I feel like I got out of the wrong  side of the bed this morning  anyway I'm just feeling a bit unusual  but yeah just um at home isolating and  though I just try out a few bits of  makeup a little bit though and then oh  yeah that's good oh yeah I mean look at  that day tonight  oh just a bit of sprucing up for the day  just stunning  God is in the details well different  happened you know that's I see what  people do to make makeup tutorials now  it's you've got rid of stunt people in  your life you've got rid of the glam  squad it's yeah your one-stop no it's  the real me yeah  [Music]  you